oh mein gott was passiert wenn euch das
anbietet das bild das wir draußen die
welt könnt ihr euch noch an den blog von
vor zwei tagen erinnern
das sind nicht ganz spontan sind svp
also mir ganz spontan zu dem festival am
nürburgring gefahren und dem sprechen
abends richtig k und sind dabei
eingeschlafen darauf gewartet haben das
kann man ja gegen floyd mayweather
kämpfen wir sagte davon dass wir floyd
mayweather gegen kanada verpasst
er wolle noch nicht ausgeträumt und sind
nicht zufrieden und sind einfach sehen
wie jugendliche nicht mal so dass das
mal als schlimmeres im leben zum
beispiel nicht gemacht jetzt läuft bevor
wir heute irgendetwas geht machen wir
uns als erst mal 70 bin ich übrigens
sagen wir machen uns breakfast heißt das
wir bestellt und spitze einer stunde
tragen aber die mich gar nichts zu tun
haben kann dass du die petra roth wenn
jetzt grad fieber gespielt
kubitschek würde ich sagen alles klar
irgendwie bin ich gerade von traurig und
die komplette woche jetzt mit games
kommen video das den ganzen partie den
ganzen coolen leuten die anderen köln
waren ist jetzt einfach vorbei und
sentimental gerade aber immer wenn ich
traurig bin denke ich mir dann halt
einfach es wurde für dienst ihr
millionen euro im jahr und damit ich
nicht mehr traurig bist du freunde ich
war einmal basketball am 1
neben nba und bist du hast nichts für
mich ist das hier
es ist gerade passiert und zwar habe ich
gerade den block drei stunden lang
geschnitten und diese kamera lag
eigentlich hier auf dem tisch in mein
handy war hier in dem laptop
eingesteckten ich wollte mein handy
melden nehmen und sie das weckt das
kabel rutscht aus dass kabel sie die
kamera wurde die kamera fällt auf meinen
fuß da ist die kamera drauf gefallen du
blödes dingen als wäre es nicht schon
schlimm genug wäre das meine kamera
einfach durch dieses keine punkte
herunter gerissen wir dann auf den boden
fällt nein sie muss auch noch direkt auf
den fußball
ich habe auf jeden fall jetzt im block
fertig geschnitten und auch hochgeladen
das gegen es ist einfach schon fast
dunkel draußen richtig doof heute ist
noch gar nicht wirklich in meinem blog
passiert eigentlich passiert
ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
ein bisschen an meiner bachelorarbeit
präsentation arbeiten kann ich die
kamera endlich ihre einstellung
überdenken erklärt ich bin der beste
blocker
freunde ich habe gerade zwei stellen an
meiner bachelorarbeit präsentation
gearbeitet und johann schütte gestellt
und wir jetzt einfach es ist noch eine
stunde braucht es hier ist scheiße ich
am romani verdienen zu übrigens hier
nochmal als indiz dafür was ich wirklich
für ein toller mensch der mich auch in
meiner wohnung oben einfach ganzjahres
deko also ein osterhasen und weihnachts
krams und allgemein die schnell das geht
unter die leute
die kompetent und so war es immer so
komisch wie wendig von youtube aber
jetzt gegessen also so sieht das essen
jetzt aus ich habe ich ja nur schnitzel
mit preiselbeeren und kapern
bratkartoffeln dann habe ich mir noch
ein weißbrot getroffen weil ich das
gleich in die tomatensuppe ja tomaten
wenn ich das gleich eintunken schöne
habe ich hier noch ein salat und hier
scheine ich gerade an einem neuen
mixtape ich habe jetzt auch gegessen und
ich schwöre euch ich habe man die
mannschaft mal zu vergessen ist fühlt
sich so an als der teufel mir wohnen
also dass
zu seinem mega geil aus und auch mehr
gesteckt diese tomatensuppe
diese schärfe macht welche zu schaffen
würde wir machen jetzt mal wieder was
ein blog was ich länger nicht gemacht
und zwar mit dem 1
wir müssen jetzt mal rausgehen wie es
überhaupt helfen soll also in dem kannst
du bitte kurz kurz ruhig sein in diesem
blog habe ich ja die umfrage gemacht das
heißt ich gehe jetzt mal hier und wir
sind
ich muss ja etwas abstimmen okay das
malteser erkläre warum rüdiger ist er
komplett egal und wir sehen zur api hat
55 prozent also heißt dieses eigene
jetzt la vie und geschaut
es ist jetzt ob das heißt orange
unterseite des eises tätscheln vorwärts
neigen oder kopf tätscheln
ich werde jetzt einfach mal so vorgehen
dass ich verschiedene dinge mit diesem
ziel macher als ich wäre das jetzt
einfach mal hinlegen die ganze zeit nur
auf die farben achten mal den kopf
tätscheln ein bisschen hin und her
bewegen und wir sehen uns dann gleich
wieder wenn irgendwas mit dem ei
passieren sollte
ich habe gerade noch kein bisschen das
alles auswendig gelernt für meine
bremsen sation letzten paar tagen noch
einmal machen dieses iphone
ich dachte schläft aber jetzt halt
wieder die fresse ich möchte dich jetzt
nicht irgendwie mal herauspicken oder so
achso und maximal zu finden beginnt die
mode passanten 6
die streiche fleischliche die ganze zeit
aber irgendwie fängt nicht an sich der
fische wieder dass alle bewegt sich
gerade von alleine ihr seht schon hier
vielleicht erkennt man das heißt ein
kleiner riss es leuchtet bund aber warum
machst du denn jetzt nicht weiter da
fluffy die streiche dass sie schon die
ganze zeit das einzige was sie gerade
hingekriegt hat die frau dass dieser
kleine risse
das war also nicht was gerade passiert
hier guckt euch das an oh mein gott ich
weiß nicht was jetzt gerade passiert ihr
seht schon hier es kann schon mal
ausgebrochen hier vorne klappte gar die
ganzseitigen platz mai geschlüpft gerade
da steht wenn das ei schlüpft soll man
die hände um das einhalten und den bau
thatcher
hier vorne hat er jetzt die ganze zeit
aus der haut hier überall gerade mit
seinem schnabel dass die die schale
kaputt weitermachen hier vorne kann man
jetzt sogar schon so ein bisschen rein
gucken und kann vielleicht sogar so ein
bisschen mithelfen ich mache ich die
schale so ein bisschen mit ab damit wir
mal schauen ob ich vielleicht ein
bisschen hier unter die arme greifen
können das ist auf jeden fall pink es
ist einfach durch das antworte darf herr
schnabel und er hat jetzt hier den
schnabel überall gegen den blick so ein
bisschen im kreis und versucht sich
jetzt hier irgendwie auswahl heraus zu
befreien wie krank ist das hier bitte
gerade freunde da ist der schnabel von
der haut sich die ganze zeit gegen die
wand gegen und versucht jetzt hier sich
irgendwie zu befreien alter hey dude
einer art fluffy gleich bist bei mir da
seht ihr seinen schnabel wieder so ein
bisschen da geht mein gott flasche
bisher ganz schön stark erhöht die
schale hier auf jeden fall auch schon
gut auf meinen tisch drauf
nach vorne kommt jetzt wer mit seinem
schnabel an das heißt jeden moment sind
wir wieder da ist er wieder da sein auge
mainboard alter was geht ab man ich hab
so ein bisschen angst ich weiß nicht ob
ich ihnen helfen soll ob ich einfach mal
selber so ein bisschen was ab machen
soll weil eigentlich sagt man ja auch
wenn kinder irgendwas auf den boden
schmeißen dann soll man das nicht
aufheben damit die lernen dass selbst zu
tun aber das ist ein fucking als wärst
mein sohn
den jetzt einfach mal mit und mache
diesen deckel hier oben ab das heißt wir
sehen schon hat der scheiß auf der
fresse das hier ist jetzt das ding ich
drauf habe ich neben den jetzt mal seit
dem hut ab und jetzt kannst du drehst
dich dennoch bewusst unternehmen sowieso
schon freisprach wie ich möchte
vielleicht aus dem bei rauskommen ich
habe keine ahnung wie lange ich hier
jetzt noch warten muss auf schlaffi aber
alter der sieht ja mal ein mega krass
aus mit diesen augen glaube das ging dem
kleinen platte jetzt vielleicht doch so
ein bisschen zu schnell hier aus dem
haus ist auf jeden fall gerade im
schlafmodus und muss jetzt natürlich
erst ein bisschen schlafen es war ja
auch anstrengend schon mal die ganze
schale hier zu zerhacken ich würde sagen
wir dass eine flasche jetzt erst mal
eine nacht schlafen war natürlich auch
anstrengender ist erst mal raus zu
kommen und so weiter und so fort und ich
würde sagen wir sehen uns dann morgen
[Musik]
es ist ein so frühes ist gerade 90 41
der tag heute so ablaufen dass ich einen
termin bei einer heilpraktikerin habe
hört sich bescheuert an es war aber
eigentlich umfang heißt also man nicht
da wo hingegen oder halbe stunde und die
nimmt dann irgendwie dass beide was
unter raschelte auf jeden fall wird die
zwischendurch den arm legte die wiese
auf die brust setzen sie sich so auf den
namen drauf und haben dann knackt zu
also irgendwann fühlt sich danach könne
man fliegen übrigens bin ich jetzt nach
wie ganze familien auf der gamescom und
deswegen werde ich krank geworden als
mantra gehen und ich glaube ich glaube
nicht dass wir jetzt mal dran
die termine und emmas hast du bot gleich
mit mir irgendwas essen zu gehen etwas
essen zu gehen
es sind gerade eine stunden und 26
minuten vergangen ich bin wieder zu
hause ankommen und leute ist das kind
hatte ich meine ist es denn zu viel
verlangt deutschland dass die
temperaturen einmal vernünftig sommer
mäßig sind das beispielsweise mal 22
grad mit ein bisschen wirr stattdessen
haben in köln gerade so circa 50.000
grad und kein wort sagen das will ich
nicht die ganze zeit und beschwert aber
es ist halt echt in köln mal viel heißt
als im rest von deutschland
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht genau ob ich denn jetzt
irgendwie raus holen soll oder nicht
weil kommen wir nicht so mache kommt da
nicht raus
warum machst du da ist als wenn ok damit
hätte ich nie gerechnet so versuche ich
jetzt bei dir du bist jetzt freifläche
ich werde hier gerade nicht böse dass
ich möchte nur diese komische verpackung
von medien ab machen alle zusammen wie
ich würde sagen ich stell dich jetzt
erstmal hier vorne ab zu deinem papa
freut da seid ihr jetzt eine familie und
ich bestelle mir jetzt was essen
so sieht das essen hier aus eigentlich
ganz geil ein bisschen zur kampagne mit
kamerateam mitzumachen spinat wissen wie
pappe diana hat gerade ihre
weisheitszähne raus bekommen
[Musik]
ich freue mich einfach so wenn ich
morgen diese prüfung hinter mir habe und
dann bei den abschlussball habe und weil
sie meinen titel bachelor in der hand
hält und danach mich endlich ja das
passiert dann habe ich endlich zeit um
so was wie piano spielen zu lernen halt
richtig zu machen und weiter und fordern
fluffy wie geht es dir da hinten
wie geht es dir hier vorne sozusagen
einmal das tut mir leid so lang
ok dann hast du dich erst mal
ausschlafen der block hat bisher
wirklich irgendwie zu 95 prozent meiner
wohnung stattgefunden weil ich wie
gesagt die ganze zeit meine
bachelorarbeit präsentation hier
vorbereitet habe aber jetzt gehe ich
trainieren wie man im jahre 2017 baut
trainiert ich bin wieder zu hause
angekommen ich bin ich habe keine ahnung
was sie mit nach wie gerade los ist was
du hast laufen gelernt wann soll ich dir
das denn bei bringen also ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht aus dem flaf wieder
hinten los
keine ahnung was glaube ich in der
zwischenzeit gemacht trainieren war aber
irgendwie laufen gelernt hast du schon
leicht stinken scheiße und das macht
einen nicht überhaupt
dass ich gerade dusche sind immer noch
28 grad in köln
nach dem schwitzen ich mache mir nudeln
und ich habe selbst auch eine note es
ist einfach gerade halb zwei gehört
schon da hinten ein drucker ist an der
gerade noch das handout aus für morgen
für meine bachelorarbeit produktion ich
bin auf jeden fall haarmühle und freue
mich einfach wenn ich das morgen hinter
mir habe befragen war das fleisch sie
denken was ich finden los bekommen werde
fluffy was denkst was ich mal alles klar
ich würde dem lockeren der stadt jetzt
allerdings auch beenden wenn ihr euch
gefallen hat würde ich mich sehr über
einen live von euch freuen ich weiß dass
ich wieder klug argumentiert kommentare
gemacht habe aber ich hatte echt viel
viel zu tun mit dieser bachelorarbeit
präsentation dafür ist dass alge stifter
so hey das doch auch cool wenn sie noch
kein abonnent von meinem kanal sein
könnte unter dem video einfach auf
abonnieren klicken dann verpasste keine
videos mehr auch wenn ihr schon ab und
seid könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken
denn dann bekommt ist direkt mit wenn
ich ein neues video hochladen sonst
würde ich jetzt sagen weil damen und
herren sehen wir uns über morgen einen
neuen flug wieder da seht ihr dann die
man kolloquium gelaufen ist welche
möglichen der bachelor arbeit bekommen
habe und ich werde auch nach hause zu
meiner familie fahren das heißt
[Musik]